shopping for clothes don't you know can
sometimes be a struggle whether you're
looking in stores or online these are
fine they're not fun
you have a mom button that what you want
we're shopping in stores when I shop for
clothes I usually buy online i buy most
of my clothing in stores so that I can
try them on I don't get this dress my
apples keeps rolling out of the bag but
I like the story it tells with the
fringe I like customer service I like
help with fit
I need someone's opinion those are too
tight those are way too tight yeah but
like way too tight you need to upgrade I
think I make her rational decisions more
online the thing I like the least is
like the crowds of people that are
shopping my favorite part is when the
thing I really want is on sale
[Applause]
look there's no R in the middle that's
just a joke I like a sale to one
businesses help change the way we shop
is the men's clothing company bonobos in
2007 bonobos was one of the first
retailers they would say they were the
first retailer actually to begin selling
clothing exclusively online for year
four years later at launch guide shops
that's bringing its online inventory to
brick-and-mortar stores it's a concept
where you try the clothes on but you
don't walk out with the shopping bags
instead everything you want is shipped
to you love that Walmart bought bonobos
over the summer for three hundred ten
million dollars three hundred and ten
million dollars catching bonobos founder
and CEO Andy done is here looking very
dapper in a suit who suit is that
bonobos struggling with what to wear
this morning yes I know you Arnie is
also senior vice president of digital
consumer brands at Walmart ecommerce
welcome back so congratulations on this
sale but you were already doing so well
what made you think let's merge together
because those don't always turn out so
well mr. Dunn well a couple mergers is
here got married in May of Steel in June
so it's been an easy breezy first half
of your life stressors Andy look here's
the thing there's a couple paths you can
take with the company you can go public
or you can do a sale and for us we
always thought we'd go public and then
Walmart came along and Mark Laurie who's
the founder of jet guide known a long
time said let's go build the leading
collection of digital brands out there
and it was too good to resist so now
you're upping Walmart grow their
e-commerce business well walmart has
been focused on e-commerce in a big way
since they acquired jet you know huge
acquisition three billion dollars back
in jet was a kind of what a mini jet was
really an attempt to build an amazing
marketplace for brands targeted at urban
Millennials and given bonobos as his
target which is the same on the men's
side mark said let's go out and build an
amazing collection digital brands
starting with bonobos starting with
ModCloth which they'd also acquired and
the chance to go out and build that with
our team was too exciting to pass up so
you're trying to take Amazon on is that
what you're doing we're looking Jeff
Bezos
back back well look here's the thing you
know you do know Jeff Bezos I've heard
of him yeah I've heard of them but when
you think about innovation right now
where it's happening is in the digitally
branded space it used to be about
selling other people's brands well we
created that bonobos was the idea that
you can actually build a brain
and online and now we figured out this
offline extension so as the pioneer in
that the chance to go scale that up and
do it across the collection is what
really excited on what are you learning
from the brick-and-mortar stores you
know we started we would have said
brick-and-mortar is over its dead and
then what we discovered about halfway
through five years in to our ten-year
journey is this concept that offline is
not dead it's just changing and it's all
about the experience it's all about
one-to-one service which is why we call
it the guide shops but you don't need
the inventory in the store you can
fulfill that three commerce so you pull
out the stock but what you put in is
this great one-to-one retail experience
so the news is that Walmart is
reportedly near a deal to add Lord and
Taylor to its its website can you tell
us anything about that well if you think
about it 1:1 e-commerce strategy has
been hey let's have one big site and I
think what we're learning from Walmart
and from Jett and from bonobos and
ModCloth and shoes.com and Moose Jaw all
these different brands that we have
under the Walmart mantle is it's about
an ecosystem it's not about just one
place people are going to shop online
its shopping with the sites that they
really love I know it's just really an
effort by Walmart and Doug McMillon to
basically say you know if we want to
survive we really do have to make sure
that we're a big player online in the
same way Amazon is forget about
surviving we want to win yeah and we
think that this is a really interesting
in a different way to win when someone's
digging you got a zag and I think
customers still love brands you know
brands are not going away
we built a beloved brand with bonobos
and so we're honored and humbled to be a
part of what Walmart's you know talk
about your campaign the role-models
campaign because you've taken
extraordinary everyday people I wish I
could think of another word for everyday
people but extraordinary everyday guys
and you're making them the face of your
brand I think that's a very different
way to go most people are getting super
models or actors or famous people well
these are Renaissance men you know you
think about Leland Melvin who you didn't
hear a bell player an astronaut or Jason
Flom what he's doing with criminal
justice reform these are guys who are
changing the world in their own little
corner of the universe and we thought
let's feature these men and make bonobos
not just about fit and service and
clothing but about the future of man
because there's a new definition of
masculinity
think so I think masculine is changing a
lot you know you think about it with you
know federal legislation around gay
marriage you think about it with the
relationship that we have now certainly
the one I've got at home with equal
partners right and you think about the
ways in which it's now okay for guys
through fashion to express their style
to express their individuality and we
thought it could be about something
greater for bonobos than just the fit of
our clothes I think you need to put
yourself in an ad Andy I'm looking at
the suit I'm looking at you on thing and
it's working women's line coming now
that you're married we made one what did
one haywire calm we spun it out my wife
seen his men well a zone inside looking
at a smile what he's definitely a chef
where it says bonobos everyday he loves
it
great company Thank You Angela Newton
Brooks